montigny le bretonneux redescend sur
terre après trois victoires consécutives
dans le championnat de nationale 2
lésigny monteyne ont concédé une lourde
défaite sur leur terrain contre le paris
saint germain ce samedi 4 février le
score 22 à 10 le secteur défaillant
l'attaquant seconde période montigny le
bretonneux n'a marqué que quatre buts en
30 minutes de jeu mais on n'a pas les
bonnes attitudes et c'est ce qui fait
qu'on n'a pas de réussite on manque
certainement un peu de confiance aussi
en nous mêmes et du coup on n'y va pas
on s'engage pas et on pêche beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup en attaque
le score le montre c'est presque
ridicule on savait qu'on jouait sur une
grosse défense
mais de là à mettre que 10 buts c'est
quand même compliqué avec beaucoup
d'échecs ont déjà ce que je regrette le
plus c'est que les consignes ne soit pas
appliquée parce que bon c'est surtout
des échecs par rapport à la gardienne
que l'on a eu
échec dû parce que la prise
d'information sur le duel face à la
gardienne n'est pas fait on a tout mis
en bas alors que je demandais depuis
plus de cinquante minutes de tir en
pleine lucarne parce qu'elle se sera
baissée sur ses appuis
cette défaite est un coup d'arrêt dans
la remontée au classement montigny le
bretonneux reste à la 9e place avec un
bilan de 4 victoires et 6 défaites
depuis le début du championnat je pense
que c'est trop tôt pour avoir des
regrets
il faut qu'on travaille on n'a pas le
temps de s'apitoyer sur ce qu'on a à
faire on sait que c'est une saison
compliquée
vu tout un tas de circonstances
maintenant il faut qu'on avance je veux
qu'on arrive à rester solide ensemble et
c'est ce qui est compliqué quand on a un
petit effectif qui enchaîne les matches
comme ça il faut qu'on arrive à rester
ensemble pour la suite la suite arrive
dès ce samedi 11 février
montigny-le-bretonneux se rendra sur le
terrain de noisy le grand gagnant
victoire impérative pour le parrot
tomber dans une spirale négative
[Applaudissements]